y seguimos con este cubrimiento especial
en directo América edición nocturna con
motivo del fallecimiento de la Reina
Isabel II y vamos a analizar ahora el
impacto que ha tenido en materia
económica este evento para ello saludo a
mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge qué tal
Muy bien Andrés Qué gusto saludarte
Jorge cómo reaccionaron los mercados a
la muerte de la reina Isabel bueno la
reacción más inmediata fue en el Mercado
de Divisas donde reinó el pesimismo tras
la muerte de la monarca la libra
esterlina cayó frente al Dólar y el euro
durante una jornada bastante agitada la
moneda de Reino Unido bajó 0,3% y se
ubicó a 1,15 por dólar por su parte el
euro subió un leve 0,1% frente a la
libra esterlina pero la moneda británica
ya cotizaba la baja desde días antes el
descenso viene desde agosto pero la
caída se acentuó Un día después de que
listros asumiera el cargo de primera
ministra del Reino Unido con un programa
basado en recortar impuestos e
incrementar la deuda pública la muerte
de la reina sin duda empujó este
pesimismo para este mercado quizás Jorge
pero el impacto económico no solamente
será en la moneda local Bueno de hecho
la muerte de Isabel II trae consigo una
serie de medidas que impactan en la vida
económica y social de Reino Unido Y es
que este plan llamado London Bridge
incluye la suspensión del sistema
financiero y de la bolsa de valores de
Londres que es una de las cinco más
importantes del mundo medios locales
consideran que su muerte podría generar
pérdidas de miles de millones de libras
esterlinas para la economía esto Porque
habría varios días de duelo donde se
produciría el cierre de casi toda la
actividad económica los analistas prevén
que el mayor impacto sea e interno para
el Reino Unido por estos cierres de
negocio y los inversionistas que no
podrán comprar en ese mercado de valores
se deben ir a otras partes del mundo y
esas operaciones no van a dejar una
derrama económica para esa nación Jorge
que datos se conocen sobre la herencia
que dejó la monarca Bueno lo que se sabe
hasta ahora es que el patrimonio que
dejó se estima en 370 millones de libras
esterlinas o unos 426
millones de dólares esto en propiedades
artes y otros activos de la realeza este
cálculo es de bloomberg y se basa en
propiedades privadas patrimonio personal
y herencia excluyendo los palacios que
no son un bien privado y deben
traspasarse en la línea de sucesión al
Trono algunos de los bienes de la reina
incluidas propiedades como la casa de
campo en Sandra house de 32 kilómetros
cuadrados que está situada en norfolk y
el castillo palmoral situado en Escocia
ambas propiedades fueron herencia de su
padre el rey Jorge pero la riqueza
personal de la reina incluye
participaciones accionarias en firma
británicas y una colección de sellos
valuada en 100 millones de libras
esterlinas Aunque El Monarca no está
legalmente obligado a dar una
declaración patrimonial se conoce que
las tres principales fuentes de ingreso
eran el pago anual de la subvención
soberana el privipurs y su patrimonio y
herencia personal la subvención soberana
que es una suma global anual que da el
gobierno es especialmente una cuenta de
gastos que cubre Los costos de viaje
seguridad personal y mantenimiento de
los palacios reales del total de los
recursos de la subvención el 60% casi 60
millones de dólares eran destinados a
financiar viajes oficiales el costo
operativo de su casa el mantenimiento
también de las propiedades mientras que
casi 40 millones de dólares eran
dedicados a la reserva este private o el
monedero Real Como se conoce que
administra un fideicomiso son los
ingresos privados que recibe del ducado
de Lancaster se trata esencialmente de
una cartera de tierra propiedades y
otros activos que se han mantenido en
fideicomiso para el soberano desde
1.399 mucho dinero de por medio Jorge
cómo se ha transformado la economía
británica durante el mandato de la Reina
Isabel II Bueno aquí algunos datos
Andrés cuando la Reina Isabel subió al
Trono británico a inicios de los años 50
es economía aún sufría el efecto del
racionamiento de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial era heredera de la Revolución
Industrial se asentaba sobre
una potente industria manufacturera y
aún era potencia comercial en el mundo
hoy en día se transformó en un centro
financiero recién independizado de la
Unión Europea y que sufre de nuevo con
los estragos de otra guerra en Europa la
guerra en Ucrania el producto interno
bruto británico en los años 50 era de
apenas 15 mil millones de libras
esterlinas frente a los más de dos
billones actuales Londres hoy es
considerado un centro financiero global
pero hace siete décadas conservaba la
importancia comercial líder de un gran
Imperio según bloomberg Reino Unido
representaba Entonces el 9% de las
exportaciones en todo el mundo ahora
solamente representa el 2%. en los años
50 El déficit comercial del Reino Unido
era unos mil millones de libras
esterlinas mientras que en 2021 se
disparó por encima de los 150 mil
millones Jorge muchas gracias por
ayudarnos a entender el impacto que tuvo
en la Reina Isabel en la economía
británica durante su reinado y también
ahora con este evento de su muerte Jorge
muchas gracias nuevamente y ustedes
televi Gracias por acompañarnos ya viene
Ángela Gómez con el debate